so hello everybody i'm really excited to
be back here with richard rowland
to continue the universal history if you
have not seen our first video
um it has really taken off and also just
sparked so much discussion
he's now flooded with emails he tells me
of all these people who want to ask
about everything
from universal history to psychedelic
since i'm really happy that that's
happening
because richard is a very interesting
person and i'm looking forward to kind
of continuing this conversation
as we move forward so richard so richard
what
what is it that you wanted us to talk
about today
so now that we've laid out the idea of
of universal history
and tried to establish the idea that the
the way that they thought about history
in the ancient and the medieval mind
that that that way of thinking about
history and of reading history still has
value and meaning to us
what i thought that we could do would be
to
uh take a a closer look at one of the
main
patterns that i see uh within western
history within
the whole medieval project and by
western i mean i mean the whole
medieval christian world um you know so
including byzantium and that
and uh uh so i thought what i thought we
could do is take a closer look at
this one of the main patterns that
manifest itself kind of over and over
again
and that really helps us to navigate
the moment that we're in right now and
that's the pattern of
christ and antichrist
so this actually starts i want to i want
to start with kind of a deep poll here
that maybe a lot of
our listeners won't be familiar with and
that is a guy
named mithridates vi of pontus
so mithridates is a super interesting
guy he
he ruled over the kingdom of pontus and
over much of anatolia
again so this is a guy he's from the
east he's specifically from anatolia
which seems to keep coming up for some
reason um and he's actually a descendant
of both alexander the great and also of
cyrus uh
so he basically he basically understood
himself
his understanding was that he was the
inheritor of both east and west of both
greece and persia right so he's living
you know anatolia is the space that's
sort of like on the border
between these two worlds and uh so he
understood himself as as
having an inherited both of these things
and and he has a lot of
let's say messianic features about his
life there was a comet in the sky that
was seen
when he was born and all this other
stuff so he's he's a really interesting
figure
and when he's quite young i think about
10 years old or so
his mother actually tries to kill him
along with along with his father
and kills his father but mithridates
escapes and he spent the next 10 or 15
years
kind of on the run in hiding and he's
traveling around to all these different
these different tribes and these
different kind of wild groups that are
on the edge of anatolian civilization
and he's making alliances he's learning
how to lead he's learning how to fight
he's learning how to poison his nickname
is
the poison king because he just poisoned
so many people
um this is in the first century bc is my
understanding
right uh yes that's right yeah yeah and
so he he also
um he also
uh uh one of the things he's really
famous for
was developing basically like a
universal antidote
and we don't know if he really succeeded
in doing it or not there's there's kind
of like conflicting you could say
conflicting evidence
but uh the thing that he's famous for is
developing something called mithridatum
is what it's usually called now named
after him and it's the idea
of basically he's got a small amount of
every single poison
in it and so you take a dose of this
every day and you build up and you know
you build up an immunity to iocan powder
for those of us who are you know
princess bride fans
um uh so so mithridates you know
he did that he had he had this dose that
was like all these herbs and
small amounts of poisons and stuff and
he took it every day
and he lived a really long time so i
don't know what's going on there i'm
pretty sure
that uh i'm pretty sure like from a
modern scientific standpoint taking a
little bit of arsenic every day is maybe
not the best thing to do
uh and and nobody really knows what was
in it no one knows yeah it's it's a lost
formula
yeah yeah it's a loss formula but during
the middle ages actually the whole lot
of people tried to
re like figure it out it was like the
philosopher's stone of poison
it really yeah yeah or yeah so anyway so
he comes back
poisons his mom and takes over takes
over the kingdom
and becomes the worst enemy
that the roman republic had fought since
hannibal barca
and basically he just becomes uh he's
he's considered one of the three great
enemies
by the romans themselves who always
respected their enemies greatly
he was considered along with pirus and
with hannibal one of the three great
enemies of the roman republic
um he's eventually defeated by pompey
the great and
dies uh according to according to
history dies by suicide of course the
story there is pretty fun
it's that he he tried to poison himself
and it didn't work uh because
theoretically he was immune to it he was
also just
an enormous man like physically enormous
very powerfully built
um so maybe maybe you know who knows but
anyway so eventually he either stabbed
himself or he had one of the slaves
slaves stabbed him um
but they when he died because he'd been
such a nuisance to the roman empire
when he died there were legends
which began to arise almost immediately
after his death
that he hadn't actually died uh these
legends that he had
uh actually gone he had a hit a wife who
was like
one of his wives was like the city and
amazon warrior
and so he had even like at one point had
this like group group of amazons like as
his bodyguard
he rolled with i mean yeah like gaddafi
yeah yeah or
or like wakanda or something yeah yeah
yeah yeah
he's a fascinating guy all the stuff
that i'm saying by the way there's a
really fun book
called uh the poison king the life and
legend of mithridates rome's deadliest
enemy
and it's by adrienne adrian mare
and you can you can find it on amazon
and audible and places like that it's
it's a really fascinating uh piece
uh of history but anyway so one of the
legends is that actually
he goes north with these sybians you
know these these amazons
to scandinavia and that he
is the origin of the gothic people
who come back for revenge against rome a
couple of hundred years later
interesting yeah so or i'm more than a
couple hundred but but
and so all the way into the time like
when when rome starts dealing with the
really serious barbarian invasions one
of the beliefs that they had in rome
was that this was mithridates coming
back and and actually they identified
mithridates with odin
and they and so it was actually a like a
pre-christian you hemorrhaging of odin
where they identified this this figure
from their past
with the this this very fierce
warrior god but who's also i mean odin's
not just a warrior god
he's a he's a trickster figure like he's
always tricking people
into things uh which is very much like
mithridates
uh and his the way that he did things so
so you have
uh so you had this idea then that
uh let's say the pattern and this is
where the pattern of
of it's it's both the pattern of christ
and of antichrist
right the idea that you have a
principality that is cut
off but then it reappears somewhere else
unexpected later on um and so
mithridates is kind of the type of this
and one of the really interesting things
that happens
uh later in roman history uh after
nero's death is that a lot of this
gets transferred to nero
so when nero dies and this is in i mean
we talked about the sibling oracles last
year right
this is in the sibling oracles nero the
resurrection of nero or the
resurrection of nero yeah um and the
idea is that nero
didn't really die but that he actually
escaped and he went to persia
um so it's always these it's always from
the east right
so he he he escapes and he goes to
persia and then he's going to come back
basically as this antichrist figure um
as as god's instrument of judgment
against the romans
um that's how it is in the sibling
oracles so there's this idea that
that uh that nero you know again the
idea of
the principality being cut off and
disappearing and coming back
now i said this is the this is the
pattern of both christ and antichrist
because of course within the hebrew
tradition
you have the idea of the stump or the
root of jesus
yeah right so the idea you know in this
is in the prophecy of isaiah so that's
in like the 700s bc
that the the line of david the line of
jesse is going to be cut off
right and so a lot of times our like our
king james translations is the root of
jesse but it's
the hebrew the word in hebrew is really
the word for a stump
and so the idea that the the line of
jesse like a tree will be cut off
and it'll be just completely obliterated
and then in a time that's unexpected
that's unlooked for they're going to
start being these shoots
that come up and that's of course you
know that's
that's the the church understands that
as the focus and as christ
so that's the that's the kind of basic
pattern that we can establish
uh and so by the time we get to the book
of revelation we see this pattern
both in christ and in the figure of
antichrist
right so you've done your uh you've done
a really great video on the the what you
call the system of a beast is that what
it's called
yeah um i'm really waiting for part two
i'm very excited
it's becoming the most complicated thing
i've ever written
i'm trying to write this this video on
the mark of the beast and explaining
what a mark is to people
it's so deep that it's i i struggle to
do it in a way that won't
uh be just go over people's heads yeah
like it just
just kind of not seem like what i want
to make it seem like so it's coming
i worked on it last night very late at
night good good i'm glad to hear that
i'm really i'm really looking forward to
it so
so in the book of revelation right you
have both
this pattern of of antichrist
right the the little horn and daniel and
the you know all that stuff right so
it's the idea of a principality that get
gets cut off and then it comes back
again
later yeah but then also ultimately
that's
also the pattern of christ you know and
so
you know it's it's not hard to
understand the antichrist is being sort
of like the dark mirror of
christ so if christ is the master
pattern the antichrist is the inversion
of that somehow
yeah but what i think a lot of people
don't understand or what they get really
hung up on
is you know you've got you've got people
who want to go and do just a purely
historical reading of revelation
until they say they'll say oh well this
antichrist figure here the beast
or whatever that's a nero it's only
narrow
it's just nero you know and the
christians mistakenly believed
that he was going to come back you know
and and he never did
and so there you can see revelation is
bunk yeah that's
man yeah i mean it's silly because like
you said there are so many versions of
this pattern
uh and it has to do with the it does
have to do with something like the
scapegoat
it has to do with something like uh the
the enemy or the evil that is cast out
but goes and wanders in the desert let's
say
yeah but that this wandering can end
that this thing can come back because
those remainders
never get dealt with there's an ancient
uh
scandinavian story about what is the
demon cert i think is he's called
where he comes to to to kind of attack
the world and judge the world
on a chariot made of everybody's
fingernails
and this is the most this is the best
image of what this is about it's like
you clip these little things off these
remainders of your body your hair
your fingernails all these remainders
and
those have a power i talked about this
in the video i did actually sorry
i realized it's a patron only video on
the symbolism of uh
of the inverted pentagram or talk about
how that was that was such a good video
the idea that black magic is about
understanding the power of these
remainders
and how if we see the world that because
we understand
that that the world has it as a totality
that anything you cut off
it has a power it has a possibility of
returning
in revenge let's say you know i don't
did you this is a totally random
question but did you ever read a book
by terry pratchett called the hogfather
i have it
someone send it to me and i have it but
i haven't read it yet it's a fun book
it's one of my favorite uh books it's
it's kind of like fantasy but it's also
satire and everything but like a major
part of the plot revolves around
collecting
all of the discarded teeth of children
so that they can so that they can do you
know do some magic like something
nefarious right
but it's you know so they have to like
infiltrate the tooth fairy's castle and
all this different stuff
and it's anyway it's it's a it's a kind
of a funny story but also like it's
it's one of those stories that has these
moments of symbolic intuition that are
just like
a little just like a little too on the
nose yeah but there are many
you know there there are many versions
of this story the problem of the
castaway is the problem of the remainder
like it's funny because talking about
santa claus the entire story of rudolph
the red-nosed reindeer the one the tv
show that's what it's about right
yeah the the land of misfit toys yeah
this idea of these
castaways that that continue to kind of
exist in the margins
and at some point uh you know when the
walls break down
they return it's the same with gog and
magog you know the idea of putting these
things
out of the world and then they they're
returning and so the the idea of the
of the antichrist is obviously
in christianity it's a way to deal with
this it's a way to understand that this
is inevitable
that as christ comes he casts a
shadow and that shadow gets
kind of put out of the world but it's
going to it has to return
for things to become complete and the
story kind of has to be resolved
in a way that will encompass
all of it together and so that's why
when i you know when i
talk to people about the image of
the the new jerusalem as being something
like that as being something like
the the or the the crown of thorns as
the crown of thorns as being an image of
trying to resolve the problem of the
of these remainders that come in the
fall that this this problem of cutting
off
uh aspects of reality and pushing them
to the outside
i really love just as a kind of a side
note i really love
thorns as a you know
in that we see in the genesis story and
of course ultimately in the crown that
christ has on his head
as a as a symbol of the fall as a symbol
of chaos because the thing with a thorn
bush
is that it's something that literally
has too many points yeah
and this is the i mean this is i mean
literally it's got too many points and
this is the
i mean that's the world that we live in
today you know it's a world where
there's
there's too much everything is vying for
significance like everything is
is disorganized there's no real
hierarchy of information
of knowledge of attention and just
everything i mean just
the news cycle twitter things like this
where everything is basically
constantly coming into our our
our our view and saying i'm the most
important thing
give me your attention uh i just had a
at a totally unprecedented rate
exactly too many points and so but
there's an idea there's a sense in which
this is part of the process it's as if
it really is the
mystery one of the mysteries of christ
which is that as this
multiplicity gets filled up in a way
that sometimes is
is like sometimes a scandal in a way
it's almost as if for christ all of this
is coming together you can't totally
discern
what's going on until finally this whole
thing gets
caught up together into a final into a
final revelation
um you know the image that christ says
that scandal must happen i always come
back
to that image you know but woe to those
by who it happens but the scandal is
part of the revelation of christ
so the spoiler is that you know jesus
wins right
um spoilers yeah but in a way that might
be very
surprising to us like that's the thing
that's the thing yeah
so so you've got something like a book
of revelation where
here's this this antichrist figure this
beast figure that is clearly nero
yeah okay and it would be
useless to deny that right because we
know
you know you can read all the things
that the early church
wrote about him and that even like
non-christian sources wrote about nero
like it wasn't just christians who
believe that nero might come back
as this really negative force right the
pagans believe that too
you know so it's so you have this figure
that's clearly nero
i would say it's coming back right now
that's what i think well okay but
you say that i don't know if you saw
this but i think it's the british museum
is it just opened this exhibit about why
maybe nero was actually not such a bad
guy
it's inevitable like i mean i when i saw
that i was like well of course what else
what else could have happened this week
you know
you know it's very hard to surprise me
at this point so so here's that here's
the inversion that we're dealing with
right now
is that is that everyone hates
constantine
you know basically i mean except for us
you know like you me and dr mario
you know like um i had a great exchange
with him
um it's really fun and and i'm actually
really glad that you guys recorded your
video
before he saw our video yeah because
because it was just like this
independent confirmation like
like the thing is like he knows so much
more detail than i do about
about constantinople itself and and so
for instance i knew about the palladium
being taken to rome
i had no idea that the constantine
brought it or had one made or whatever
in constantinople but but like that that
really like takes that troy connection
we were talking about
makes it brings in it is in a way
like he wanted it to not be troy but
troy at the same time like
he wanted to to create something that
was both connected to the ancient but
totally new at the same time
yeah so i loved i loved that video it
was great but you know everyone everyone
hates
constantine so but even as we're hating
on constantine you know they were
talking about taking on statue of him in
york
as part of i don't know if they ever
actually did it but
back when like you know america was
tearing down all the confederate
monuments and things like this in
england they were they were doing
something similar
and one of the things that they were
talking about uh was
was you know there's this con this this
statue of constantine in new york which
i think is actually my cover photo on
facebook right now
yeah i saw it there yeah yeah but they
were there so they were talking about
like taking it down
i don't know if they did or not i hope
they didn't but uh so even as they're
like trying to get rid of constantine
they're saying hey but maybe nero wasn't
such a bad guy i mean like
if you think about what's going on right
now yeah it's very much
it's it's exactly the pattern of
antichrist right yeah and
there's but it's the pattern of nero is
really
powerful like in terms of if you want to
look at
if you want to understand what's
happening now because one of the things
people struggle to understand
is how what we notice around us right
now is a
weird uh a weird mix of
ultimate decadence and tyranny on the
horizon
and and people think well how like how
is that possible how can you have both
extreme degeneracy and tyranny
at the same time but if you want to
understand that look at nero
and you can see how that plays itself
out yeah
yeah adequate and how nero imposed his
degeneracy on others
nero's you know like his desire to do
that is because
a lot of people think like well just let
people be degenerate like does it
it doesn't matter but that's not how it
plays out it ends up coming into a point
of tyranny
where nero was imposing his all his
darkness
on the people around him and the people
submitted to him
i see you're an artist
um i was just thinking about
about this the other day like what is
the significance of the fact that nero
thought of himself as an artist like
that's what he saw himself as doing
i mean if we you know the
the story about his death is that his
last words were something like
how great an artist the world is losing
you know something like that right
so what's this i mean what is it you
mean in the world where
okay 20 years ago the idea
the things that we're seeing the u.s
president do would have been completely
unimaginable
now when bill clinton went on the
arsenio hall show and played his
saxophone
the world went crazy this was like the
massive scandal like how can the
president
be involved in this entertainment world
and now it is taken
completely for granted donald trump was
a wrestling villain
like donald trump was donald trump has
so much of nero
like not all the aspects of nero but he
has certain aspects of nero in him like
there are even some people who are
afraid he's gonna come back exactly
or want him to come back because some
people at the time of nero wanted him to
come back too
yeah yeah so he i don't think i don't
think donald trump is like it's totally
nero but i think that there are elements
of nero popping up like the idea of the
entertainment president the idea of
the the the president as a spectacle
you know all of this is becoming almost
taken for granted
we we think this is completely abnormal
but it's taken
it's completely taken for granted yeah
so
yeah so
the beast barack obama went to work for
netflix
yeah right like this is something which
in any
i mean it was started even with ronald
reagan like the idea that that an actor
could become president
uh you know tell the the founding
fathers that they would have just
laughed in your face
well tell me i mean tell anyone i mean
like
even even pagan rome despised actors
like actors were the lowest
they're the they're the lowest level of
society like they're under prostitutes
as far as
respectability goes in the ancient world
and so when
when you have somebody like it wasn't
just
it was just it wasn't just nero like
there was some decadence leading up to
uh up to near so for instance during the
reign of tiberius caesar
um according to i think it's tacitus
uh one of the historians i'm pretty sure
it's tacitus um
he talks about the riots and the street
fights that broke out in rome during the
reign of tiberius
over these rival troops of dancers
because there was like one troop of
dancers that some of the aristocracy
backed and there was one troop of
dancers that the
emperor really liked and people are
having fights like riots in the street
over these different things and and
tacitus saw this i think
rightly as a sign of
as a sign of the decadence and the sort
of the impending
you know problems in roman society
because you had
people actors and dancers and those are
sort of the same thing in
you know at this time in history who who
are supposed to be on the very bottom
strata of society
and now suddenly they're driving policy
and they're driving
intrigue and they're driving politics
and basically like if you had an
actor driving politics um
you know it's the same thing with like
somebody like uh
uh what's his name joaquin phoenix's
character in in gladiator
yeah commodus commodus who really did
fight in the
in the arena like that's a thing he
historically did
in fact one of the things that communist
did i just have to go on a little tiny
commodus rant here i'm very sorry
one of the things that commodus did is
that he would he would get
a bunch of crippled war veterans
together and he would tie them all up
like 10 or 10 or 15 of them
tie them up in a big bundle in the
middle of the arena of course they're
crippled they're hobbled they can't walk
and then he would dress as hercules and
like the lion-skinned cape and
everything
and take a club and and beat them to
death one by one
in the arena for his own amusement and
the amusement of people around i mean
these are crippled war veterans who
can't fight back
right and and he would say what he would
say was that he was hercules
slaying the giants yeah that was that
was what he yeah so
so i think you're absolutely right like
this this idea of like a celebrity
like an actor a an entertainer an artist
uh then you know suddenly becoming
like the the highest thing like the
principality that's now driving things
like that's
that's definitely part of the pattern of
antichrist and it's really
i don't know it's really interesting to
watch what's going on right now on both
sides like
you know in in america right now
republican or democrat
like you the same pattern is
is go is happening yeah yeah it's a
circus
so the beast in revelation decided to
kind of get us back on track a little
bit yeah but the the
beast in revelation is nero right but
he's also more than just nero
right uh this is something we talked
about in our previous video
reality lays itself out in these fractal
patterns right
so that you know these patterns that we
have happening over and over and over
again
and what the the you know what's good so
what's going on
in revelation is is taking
taking history and recent history that
the history
that uh you know
especially like the recent pain of
persecution and
of you know wondering okay where is god
in all of this pain that's going on
around you right which is
a very frequently asked question you
know
um and and then taking taking history
and looking at history really through
the lens of the liturgy and i
i'm you're probably aware of this but
there are there are now quite a quite a
number of biblical scholars and
and also some people who have done a
sort of more mystical read
of of actually looking at the structure
of ancient christian liturgy
and then reading the book of revelation
through that structure
and so you actually see you know there's
this moment
you know where uh where john eats the
book
right and that sort of corresponds to
you know so there's that's where it
corresponds to the
the you know the moment of communion and
the liturgy so the idea is that you get
this one vision of history
that's like before communion and then
the whole thing is recapitulated again
but it's it's through the eyes of like
through through the sacramental lens so
you actually sort of get
this view of history twice and you know
i'm not a i'm not a revelation scholar
um i don't know how much there is or
isn't to that i think it's very
interesting
but but i think that on a certain like
symbolic sense or a sense of you know
the patterns that we find
in the book of revelation i think
there's there's definitely something
true about that
so it's basically so what revelation is
doing then it's taking
it's taking history but it's it's saying
there's something more going on here
than just
history yeah right something is
something more is going on here than
just the things that happened yesterday
you know that the things that happened
yesterday actually participate in this
cosmic pattern
the end of which is that
the new jerusalem will descend right
yeah so you can you can sort of take
comfort
in the final in the final victory of
christ and so we have so we have these
two patterns so we have the pattern of
antichrist
which also appears as a kind of mock
resurrection or as a resurrection we see
it
in script in revelation itself as the
idea of the
fatally wounded beast that returns
to prove the power of the of the beast
and so you can see that almost like as a
mock resurrection we saw it in the storm
nero
we see it as this the return of this
this evil figure whether it be cert in
the ancient uh
in those kind of ancient cosmologies
whether it be the unleashing of gog and
magog at the end of the world
all of this is part of how when you come
to the end of things
that which has been rejected will
reign again it will show itself because
it has been cast out to the edge of the
world
and so when you get there it's like you
know you're traveling there waiting for
you exactly it's like you're traveling
you're traveling towards the end and you
keep
you push these things back right you
push other things back because they're
not part of the world like they're not
they're not conducive to the existence
of the world but then at some point
you reach the end where there's more of
that which you rejected
than that which where you came from and
so you end up in the
in the circus and and you know the freak
show all of this kind of stuff that
that chariot of the world exactly and so
so the idea of this this
idea of the return of antichrist or the
appearance of this
at the end of the world makes sense even
in terms of uh any normal
any normal process of the development of
any story or any cycle or any
you know any anything that that exists
um and so then you so you have this
pattern of antichrist
but then there's a bigger pattern or
there's something which
there's a mystery which which flips it
back
you know and like which defeats
antichrist or uses antichrist against
itself or
swallows antichrist you know there's
it's hard to sometimes
completely understand it but it's as if
you know when you reach the end
all these things even the scandals even
the breakdown all of this then
suddenly gets brought together and it
makes sense
in the whole so maybe maybe a good
example of this
that that we can give people to sort of
like key into on a narrative level
uh would be the arthurian uh material
uh which is really important for
english-speaking people even though
ironically like most arthurian material
actually comes from france
um but uh it's it's funny like in in the
middle ages they basically considered
there
there were three kinds of stories or
three cycles of stories that were worth
telling and retelling
there was the matter of britain which is
written mostly by french people there's
the matter in
matter of france which is written mostly
by italians and then there's
and then there's of course the matter of
rome which is like the old greco-roman
yeah the ancient the yeah the ancient
stuff the ancient mythology right
um and basic and and people realized
that there was a high degree of fiction
involved in these things like they
weren't naive they just didn't really
like but that didn't bother them no yeah
exactly um yeah and the matter of rome
also included alexander which is yeah
matter of
included alexander uh yeah yeah
so to talk a little bit last time we
talked about the idea that
that britain is founded by trojan exiles
and that
constantine kind of comes out of this uh
and if you read
jeffrey of monmouth he has this idea
that there's this cons
there's this idea in the the genealogies
that he presents for constantine and
ultimately for arthur
where the the the proper line
keeps getting lost and that survives
somewhere else so it was like
there was a so the idea is you have like
here's the king this guy's the the rifle
king of britain
but then he dies and all of his kids get
killed except for the youngest son who
was in france at the time so he survives
and he comes back right so it's the idea
of
the principality that gets cut off and
then resurfaces
and it happens over and over again until
uh
until eventually arthur kind of comes
about and so arthur has
multiple iterations of this pattern of
the like
the messianic pattern in his in his
lineage already
um and so this idea so the idea is that
this line of romance
of these the idea of roman british
trojans eventually produces via this
repeated pattern
it produces uther pendragon and of
course his
is more famous than arthur and i just
have to point out here that if somebody
says
you know starts talking you know a few a
few years ago like maybe 100 years ago
there was this huge search
for the historical king arthur and every
every few decades like that becomes a
thing again
um i think the most recent time was like
in the early 2000s where that was like a
really big
focus in academia uh but if somebody if
somebody talks about the historical art
king arthur being a survival of a roman
british general or something like that
they're not really contradicting the
legendary material
and they're not really saying anything
very important about it
right because the whole story of arthur
is the story of the seed falling to
earth
being lost and then shooting up again in
kind of this unexpected place
you and and of course in the case of
arthur something you said in our
previous video
is that england is the edge of the world
yeah right so
so so we have the seed
falling to earth being lost and then
shooting up again on the margin
of the western of the margin of the
roman world um
and of course you know this is the this
is the messianic pattern right again
going back to the idea of the stump of
jesse which is the springing up again
of the long lost davidic kingdom once
again on the margin of the roman empire
um and then he becomes the pantokrator
you know the idea is that christ becomes
something beyond the roman emperor
himself
which nonetheless contains the idea of
the roman emperor which is by the way
one of the things that
uh happens in in some of the arthurian
stories
uh arthur actually is sort of
acknowledged as as like the emperor
um and it's that's in mallory and some
other places yeah there's some there's
some versions where they
actually take rome yeah yeah
so which is amazing if the uh
if the story of arthur contains christ
we shouldn't be surprised that it also
contains
antichrist right that there's something
and and this actually begins it with
with arthur's birth that there's
something ambiguous and even kind of
sinister sort of left-handed
about the parentage of arthur himself so
in the very early legends
uther pendragon is is actually himself a
shape-shifter
so he he he changes shapes and uses
those powers to beget an illegitimate
child
on on princess e grain of cornwall and
in the later this is later amended that
he did this with the help of merlin
who we probably just need a whole video
to talk about maybe
merlin because and i know you've done
some in the past but he's a he's a very
interesting figure
um so by the time of
uh mallory's la mort d'arthur uh the
idea of illegitimacy is actually removed
from the story it's clarified
that okay yes uther did rape egrain
but when arthur was conceived it was
already after they've been legitimately
married so like they have to sort of
clarify
that arthur is actually a legitimate son
and therefore it's okay for him to be
king and all this stuff
um but the problem
here of illegitimacy that exists in the
seed of the arthurian story
is never fully removed it just gets
trans transferred
to these other characters in arthur's
immediate circle
so the story of arthur that develops
particularly in the francophone world
um and again most of the stories that we
remember as
as the arthurian legends like lancelot
guinevere the holy grail all that stuff
come from french authors yeah yeah um
there are these really intricate
patterns of you could say sexual
deviancy
uh in these stories right which include
things like incest adultery cuckolding
um and i think that
these stories are difficult they're
they're problematic
um i hate that word problematic i should
i shouldn't use that um but they're
they're difficult they're difficult to
sort of like look at and respond to
and uh you know to the point that when i
was a when i was a kid i wasn't actually
allowed to read the arthurian stuff
and it wasn't it wasn't really because
my parents like had read it themselves i
don't think but they just they just sort
of knew that like there was some
adultery and some other stuff happening
and so i wasn't actually allowed you
know
i mean i read them anyway you know i
read uh i read
howard pyles the boyzone king arthur
which actually doesn't have any of that
in it you know it's kind of
sanitized um uh and just really fell in
love with the arthurian stories as a
as a as a kid but i think that
people who have been paying attention to
your videos recently especially
and and this is the this is the little
lil nas
x or i don't even know how to say his
name uh but um
uh this the little nas x king arthur
connection that that all of your viewers
have been waiting for here
okay um i think that if people go back
and watch that video that you made on
little nas x and juan division
talking about talking about uh
the pattern of witchcraft right and and
you know
sexual deviancy and all and the way that
all relates to each other
that you will actually be able to
understand something really profound
about the arthurian story
um and that is uh that you know in the
most popular versions of the arthurian
legend
arthur's relationship with his queen
guinevere
is sterile right and there's no
biological cause given for this in fact
it's it doesn't appear to be like a
problem with arthur right he he does
actually sire
a son uh due to a case of sort of
accidental incest with his with his
half-sister
more gauze uh and and this this
character more gauze you know is the
queen of
orkney she's really interesting because
she's
she's from an island in the middle of
the sea right this you know orkney is
this
basically a rock in the middle of you
know the north sea
um so she's from an island in the middle
of the sea you can think about the the
symbolic implications there and then and
and she is
uh she's also the sister of morgan le
fay you know who's this
uh and and like her she's associated
particularly
particularly in the later literature
both more gauze and morgan le faye
are associated with witchcraft so the
point that eventually the two of them
are combined
into a single character so in most
modern retelling to the story
they combine these two characters
because there's this sort of sense
there's this intuition that they're a
little redundant
and morgaz is herself she's unfaithful
to her own husband multiple times
and all four of her sons including
mordred who is
arthur's you know bastard child yeah
they're portrayed
in the francophone arthurian material
and this includes gawain right who is
who is actually like a great dude in the
british story like he's the he's the
original king arthur's best knight
and then he eventually gets replaced by
lancelot in the french versions of of
the arthurian material
and when he's french you know right
because he's because because yeah
yeah because lancelot is french and and
and so when he does then
suddenly all of these guys from the
orkneys which if you're french that's
the
the literal edge of the world right um
they become they're they're portrayed as
being uncouth
dangerous capable of both great loyalty
but also great harm
like they're they're deeply loyal until
they think you've betrayed them even if
they're wrong and then they stab you in
the back
yeah um they are in other words sort of
you could say shifty characters like the
sea
right and so and so this doesn't like i
said this includes gawain
um and uh although even in the
in the british versions and this is
still in in mallory gawain
gawain has powers that are cyclical they
that they
he becomes stronger or weaker with the
cycle of the movement of the sun across
the sky so like
he's he's strongest at noon and he's
weakest at night so there's something
even even in his british origins there's
something like cyclical and kind of
wave-like about about him
uh but the second reason for arthur's
lack of a legitimate heir is that he is
cuckolded by by guinevere and lancelot
right so
guinevere carries on an also sterile
affair with with lancelot
uh who has an illegitimate son of his
own
right so again the problem is not lance
a lot lancelot can totally have kids um
and
lancelot's illegitimate son is galahad
who is like the the only like
the only really pure righteous virginal
knight
in the uh in the you know in the later
arthurian
uh versions of the legend so in the
uh and so what we can see there is kind
of this perpetuation of that uther
to arthur fractal pattern of you have
like a wicked
father or like a a maybe not so much
wicked but just like a shifty father
who begets this this totally righteous
son right
um that has to do like just to help
people understand also so we
in order to understand this we always
have to remember
that this is happening on the edge of
the world right the arthurian stories
are about
how it's almost like how can there be
resurrection or how can
the seed be planted in unrighteousness
and and
and come up in righteousness like how is
that possible like how does the world
end and start again
and so the the those all these irregular
patterns that you see
all the sexual deviancy all the incest
all of this
has to do with the problem of dealing
with this and
and it was a way for these french
authors to sort of
take their own take what's going on in
their own society
and then place it on the edge
so they can deal with it i think a
little bit yeah but it's also it's also
um it's also trying to deal with the
mystery
like the mystery of of something of
resurrection or the mystery
of the you know this is one of the
strangest and most difficult mysteries
that you find in scripture which is the
the mystery of the levite
the idea of how resurrection comes out
of death through
a a uh through a uh a taboo act
you know and so right the incest of the
leverage
is the is justified but it in any other
situation the leverage is actually
you know the idea of taking your
brother's wife is completely a sin like
it's a sin it's a taboo it's a
it's a it's a it's it's unacceptable
because it breaks it
it breaks the laws of causality um it
breaks the laws of natural causality
it's like if you marry
if you have a child with your with your
uh brother's wife than
that child like what is he to you he's
because
he's a confused identity because he has
he has he has multiple sources and is
that your nephew or is that your son
exactly and so that's that's the problem
of incest is that it actually
breaks the world apart uh in in
confusion
but so with the idea so you can
understand that that's kind of what's
happening
on the edge of the world all this
confusion all this breakdown
but in that darkness you know you could
almost say like despite that darkness
then a seed appears in that darkness
that
becomes the the seed for the future
world
you know um and so it's it's very
mysterious it's a mysterious pattern and
it's a dangerous
it's a dangerous pattern if you take it
the wrong way yeah but it's
it's also it's also very much a
christian pattern so so this
the the thing that's really interesting
to me about mordred
right so so arthur's illegitimate son
it's his nephew but it's his son
yeah and by the way there's that that
pattern that basic pattern of
accidental incest followed by a
character who is your nephew but then
ends up killing you
uh that's actually also in scandinavian
legends um in fact it's alluded to in
beowulf
um that's alluded to in this very
so almost every time in medieval
literature when somebody when the text
makes
makes a point of of saying and so and so
was so-and-so's nephew
and he succeeded him that's a way of
saying that some something happened
there
like it's it's it's uh it's like a you
know it's like a nice way of saying
yeah something happened here that
shouldn't have happened but so in
in the sort of the final version of the
arthurian legend um
mordred it's mordred himself who rats on
lancelot and gwynevere
he's the one that reveals the adulterous
affair of his aunt
who sort of been his mother right but of
his aunt and king arthur's best knight
uh which what's what's interesting is
and and t.h white in his
in his retelling of the story he really
suggests that arthur probably knew
this was going on the whole time i mean
how sort of how could you not know
right but exposing the sin publicly
in this way like uncovering the
nakedness right
forces arthur to confront it and the
resulting
fallout destroys the destroy society
destroys the round table
so the sterility of arthur's marriage
and the way that it brings about the
downfall of his kingdom
which is kind of the symbolic end you
could say of the trojan
roman british line after that it's the
saxons who come in
you know aka the english right they take
over
um but i think that this this
this pattern is actually foreshadowed in
the legend of excalibur
right the the sword you know you know
arthur's legendary sort
and so in the version that mallory has
there are
two different swords there's the sword
and the stone but that's not that one
yeah that one actually breaks in battle
and so he's given excalibur
as a replacement by the lady of the lake
and again there's this idea there's this
feminine
presence in the water
which is very which is related to like
there are all these
like sort of troublesome feminine
characters in the arthurian legend and
they're all tied to like bodies of water
in some way
so but in this case it's a positive
presence right so the
feminine presence in the water and she
gives arthur the gift but what most
people don't remember
is that in the main version of the story
in mallory
it's not one gift it's two gifts there's
the gift
of the sword and anybody
injured with a sword well like the sword
makes wounds that can't be healed okay
and that's what the sword does
but there's also a second gift and the
second gift is the
scabbard and in the legend if you wear
the scabbard
any injury that you're dealt will heal
right and so it's so basically there's
this
this in the get there's the capacity to
both wound and and to heal
and of course the the
in mallory the the scabbard which of
course the the word for scabbard in
latin is i'll let people go look it up
but it's
it's it's a sexual word like where do
you put a sword
right yeah um uh
early on in his career arthur is tricked
out of the scabbard the possession of
the scabbard
which is the proper resting place for
his sword by morgan le fay
so morgan le faye actually tricks him
out of a scabbard steals it
and throws it into a lake and so arthur
for the rest of his life he has the
sword but he doesn't have a proper
resting place
for the sword hence the sterility of
hence the sterility right
and so so the idea is that if you think
about the way that that more gauze and
morgan lafaye are often sort of
conflated as the same character
and so morgause is or where morgan le
faye
is the witch that steals arthur's seed
right so arthur has this bastard child
it makes it impossible for him to bear a
legitimate heir
and note that by the way we've now come
full circle all the way back from
the greek princess that gave giant birth
to the giant albion
right this idea that you had you had
an improper union with a principality
that results in the creation of this
monstrous child
and so the resulting illegitimate heir
of mortred
manifest here as antichrist and of
course the arthurian legend ends with
this apocalyptic battle
you know cam laden when where where
uh mordred and arthur injure each other
arthur kills his son and then arthur is
himself
mortally wounded yeah and what maybe a
lot of people don't know is that in the
middle english litter of mort arthur
mordred is wielding another one of
arthur's sword and the sword that he's
wielding
is the sword clarend which is which
which is arthur's sword of peace
it's not supposed to be used in war it's
only supposed to be used to knight
people
and for other ceremonies but it's never
supposed to be drawn at violence
and you can think about in going back to
the the apocalypse
the the promise of peace that's
associated with the beast
with the antichrist that this is what
people believe he's going to bring he's
going to bring peace
so i think that arthur's death um and
and
it's notable that the most famous
versions of his story are always called
the death of arthur you never called
that there's no story called the life of
king arthur
you know there's the death of arthur um
and and arthur's death involves two
movements that that involve magical
women in the sea and the first is the
return of the sword
so when mallory arthur instructs one of
his knights to return excalibur to the
lady of the lake
of course it takes three tries the sword
is beautiful he doesn't want to throw it
away
but he eventually casts it into the lake
where the lady catches it and it returns
to the place that it came from
and the second is the passage of arthur
himself and this is
to me one of the most mysterious things
in uh medieval literature
is that arthur is taken away to avalon
to the island of apples
uh to be healed of his wound and he's
taken away by three magical queens
one of whom is morgan le faye like
what's going on there why has she
switched sides
what is happening uh and and so in in in
mallory
you know to finish the story out
gwenevere and lancelot end their lives
the only
only with the only happy ending that
you could have in a story like this
which is they they both become
monks they both become monastics and
they they end their lives
lancelot as a hermit and guinevere as
the abbess of the monastery
um they take monastic vows and they
become holy they repent
right and so in this way you can see the
sterility of arthur's reign
is transformed into the holiness of
consecrated celibacy
so there's this resurrection that
actually kind of takes place there
and arthur himself continues uh
to participate in this same pattern
which gives him birth so he becomes
the once and future king which is almost
the very last lines of the death of
arthur the lord arthur
is you know here lies arthur the once
and future king so there's this idea
that arthur is going to return to
britain one day you know in the eschaton
right um he becomes the once and future
king he becomes the seed that falls to
earth
or goes over the sea you know to the
margin
so he's going to spring up in that
unlooked fourth place and i think it's
the the fact that it's not just the
antichrist that's on the margin but it's
also the
messiah the messianic figure that goes
to the margin
so that when you reach there you hit the
antichrist first
but then christ is also there right
there he's he's filled all things with
himself
yeah that's the image of christ moving
from east to west that you find in
scripture like that
you know like like lightning the moving
from east to west
that you know that it's this is this is
the the hardest thing is to understand
so for example like you said
you know why is morgan lafey there or
why is morgan le faye part of those that
bring arthur into
this hidden place you know for him to
return yeah and i think that
this is this is this is of course the
this is these are attempts to try to
deal with this problem like to deal with
the problem of the end
and to deal with the problem of
you know how is it that how is it that
things can start again without
re-encompassing even let's say the dark
elements of the story
you know it's it's it's difficult
because you know the
this is this is like the final this is
the final image is
is the idea that somehow all of these
things will participate
in right in the eschaton in some
transformed way
and it's hard to totally understand it
we can see it like we can have a little
glimpse of it
i think and the conversion of rome is a
place where we can have a glimpse of it
you know where as rome was
antichrist was the you know rome
destroyed the temple
rome persecuted christians you know the
emperors did all of that
but then in a strange
turn you know from diocletian
who was also this persecuted and
persecuting emperor
to uh to constantine who kind of changed
all
kind of flip the story but also reuse
the elements of the story
right we have a sense that you know
there's a puritan sense that we always
kind of have in our mind which is that
that christ brings a kind of purity
where all the things
are going to be cast aside and right and
and there'll be something new but that
that new has to be nonetheless made
out of the the gathering in of of
everything together and so there's like
a destruction and a recreation
but that return to potential and that
bringing together of a new
body has to be made out of that which
was there before
and so what's the difference this is
this is a question that i have like i'm
not sure you can even answer that
what's the difference between um the
demon cert who gathers the fingernails
of all the fallen
to create uh a chariot on which to
destroy the world
what's the difference between that and
the resurrection of the dead
like there's a difference of course
there's a difference there has to be
and and but the fact that they look like
each other
the fact that they look like each other
makes it difficult i think makes
you understand why in scripture there's
a sense in which
even christians will be duped by
antichrist right
because it's going to look like the
resurrection he says even if it were
possible
he would deceive even if it were
possible the elect right it's the idea
that
a lot of people and of course this is
why you know saint john in his
his his letter to his spiritual children
he he's warning his
his his you know you know you know there
there are many antichrists will come
into the world you know that's what he
tells that's what he tells them
he's saying listen these antichrist
figures are going to pop up and people
are going to say
oh there's christ oh there's christ oh
there's christ right and
that every time somebody says that you
have to
just be still because
like what i mean when christ like people
will know there won't be any ambiguity
about it right
um so this is
this is interesting to me because one is
i think that it's the difficulty and
telling the difference between these two
things
that is why some christians get hung up
on the idea of universalism
um because you know there is this the
sense in which
all the margins are accounted for and
but there's also the sense in which like
there will be some things that will be
outside the walls of the city and sort
of like perpetually
eternally forever outside the walls of
the city some things can't
be integrated yeah one of the images of
the new jerusalem in
revelation it says that that all the
glories of all the nations will be
gathered into
the new jerusalem it's like that's a
beautiful way of understanding it's like
all that which is glorious of all the
stories yeah will be gathered into that
final image
um but like but then there's also things
that won't be gathered in like
you know there are aspects which will
that that will
but it's hard to understand it because
okay so here's another image
it also says that there will be no ocean
right no no more
c no more c yeah that means that there's
no remainder
yeah so i don't totally understand it i
mean obviously
obviously i can't understand it but it's
like this image of
on the one hand this image of the new
jerusalem because there are these images
where it says like out that there are
things that are outside like when the
dogs and
there's all these images of what is
outside of the jew jerusalem
but but then but then there's also this
image that there's nothing remaining
these two contradictory images are
difficult to for me to reconcile that's
why revelation is so difficult to think
about
yeah so so this this idea
of you know the principality who's cut
off and returns
right obviously you have arthur is is
the example that most people who are
listening this video are going to be
really familiar with
yeah but i just want to point out that
in the middle ages
this pattern manifests itself in places
other than britain
so for instance there are there are
stories about
the idea that charlemagne is going to
come back really i didn't know i had no
idea yeah there are stories
the stories about the return of uh
either
charlemagne or frederick ii uh the holy
roman emperor frederick ii
the idea that you know in the final
showdown with the enemies of
christianity right in other words
basically the final showdown with islam
that charlemagne or frederick
will return to lead the armies of the
christians in kind of one final battle
in denmark um it's actually not a king
it's one of charlemagne's paladins oger
the dame
uh or holgar donsk who
is the he's the one that's going to
return
um and uh he's
and there's a 16th century century
legend about him actually
uh conquering all of the countries from
jerusalem at the center of the world
all the way to paradise in the east so
the idea is that he went all the way
from the center to the margin
and basically converted all of them to
the christian faith
and so then the idea is that he's going
to
uh he's going to he's he's sleeping now
he's slumbering
right and that he's going to come back
and rescue denmark
which is on the edge of the world right
he's going to come back and rescue
denmark and it's in its hour of need
kind of at the end of time
uh in your video with dr mario you
talked about the
the uh the you know the marble emperor
right this idea that that constantine
paleologus that he you know who dies in
battle with the turks
you know you know not all of the last
the not all the byzantine emperors
uh in the in the waning days of the
empire were like awesome people let's
just say
um but there's a reason why things wane
yeah
yeah there's a reason why things the
reason they were in decline at that
point yeah but the last guy
i mean he goes out the way that you're
supposed to go out right he you know at
least from a
at least from a the perspective of a
germanic philologist right you're
supposed to you're supposed to die
facing the enemy right but there's this
legend you know that
that he he didn't die that he was
basically like turned into marble
by an angel and buried beneath the gate
of constantinople
and that one day he'll awaken and he'll
return
you know um yeah there are these stories
they're crazy stories about the fall of
constantinople about
how all the all the the priests and the
people serving the
that they were serving the liturgy
during the attack
and that all the priests and the people
actually kind of entered into the walls
without finishing the the liturgy
without reaching
the the point of communion and that you
know at the end they will come out and
serve the last liturgy and uh
wait but it's a it's a it's very
romantic but it also
it also is a testimony to the
the pattern of this resurgence of light
the resurgence of
of the pattern itself that how as the
pattern breaks down
there is in that breakdown a promise
that it's going to return
inevitably because it's what holds the
world together
so in that in that kind of in that
legend
um i think there's there's something
particular
about the the the very byzantine
insistence the very christian insistence
that there is something liturgical to
the
to the pattern of the world right so
that so you can think about
this idea that we find i think that i
think that this is in um
uh saint nicholas kovaci loss in his the
life in christ but
i could be wrong but there's this idea
that we find in the fathers
that communion is the eschaton
right that that in in some sense and
like this is why
um and i know that you've recently had a
conversation with eugene
uh but alaskan which i'm really i'm
really excited to see
um but in in his book in laura's which i
think is a really important book
uh for where we are right now you know
one of the things that one of the main
themes in loras is that a lot of people
are anticipating the end of the world
because they're approaching the end of
the sixth millennium since the creation
of the world according to their the
byzantine reckoning
and so a lot of people are anticipating
the end of the world
and but there's this one point where
where uh
one of the priests in the book basically
says listen you don't know when the
world is going to end but you have a
pretty good idea of when you're going to
die
so prepare for that right like like i
i know as a as a matter of fixed
certainty that sometime in the next
50 or 60 years i'm going to die like
you know that's that's a you know bit
you could bank on it
you know and so so uh but but there's
there's this there's the sense that you
know that's kind of related to that that
you know when you take communion you
know even if you're
you know in some some cities you know
some cultures in the middle ages you
know a lot of people only
only commute at easter and christmas or
or only at easter you know but
but this this idea that communion is
the well this is insane maximus there we
go this in his ecclesias
ecclesiastical mystico mr gogy mr goji
he
he talks about this idea you know that
the
that every part of the liturgy
corresponds to
a moment in history of salvation and
that the
for instance the dismissal of the
catechumens is the last judgment
right and that so what's beyond that
which is the eucharist it's the liturgy
of the faithful
you know is the that's the eschaton
that's the
that's the the life of of god the life
of the trinity the life of the age to
come
so you've got to you've got to prepare
yourself
for that um that you know don't worry
about like when is jesus coming back
you know like we know that jesus is
coming to my mouth like this sunday so
get ready you know confess and
prepare yourself but the
so this idea then that the liturgy is
interrupted
in the fall of cancer's constantinople
and that
it's going to be finished one day that's
yeah
it's it's the eschaton itself right like
that is the
like that's that's a very true pattern
like that's a that idea
would have made really deep intuitive
sense to people in the middle ages
you know um you know even if it's like
really
fabulous or like difficult to get your
you know like no one's treating it like
as a historical
you know fact or something like that but
it's but it's but there is a sense in
which the liturgy was interrupted
but it's okay but it but it is going to
finish you know like
it it will um so maybe tell us about
i could have i think tell us about the
last emperor the virgin that's found in
the apocalypse that's that's what i was
getting to and i think that we could get
to the end of this and then just sort of
tease ethiopia
and then maybe come back and and talk
about it in another video
yeah um so this is in again this is the
apocalypse of pseudomethodius
um so there's this idea that
that we have in the in the apocalypse of
the pseudo of pseudomethodius the
two ideas that are really important one
is the coming of the antichrist
right and of course the apocalypse of
pseudomethodius is really dealing with
the rise of islam and why is you know
jesus has already come
and the empire converted so why are we
losing like what's going on
you know but what's really interesting
is that the
the uh the the actual antichrist himself
does not come from
islam in in the apocalypse of methodist
that he
follows the church fathers in saying
that the antichrist is going to come
from the tribe of dan that he's going to
basically he's going to be
one of these for in other words from one
of these
israelite tribes that was wiped out that
vanished
but is going to again resurface
at the end right and so he talks about
the antichrist and he says this man is
born at corazon
and will be raised at the sata and will
rule at capernaum and corazon will be
glad because he was born in her
and beseda because he was raised in her
and capernaum because he will have ruled
in hers he's quoting
old testament prophecies and he says for
this reason
in the gospel the lord three times past
the sentence of woe saying woe unto thee
corazon woe unto thee the seda and unto
thee capernaum if thou has been exalted
unto heaven
thou shalt be brought down to hell so
these are the places where christ did
like most of his earthly ministry
and those are the places where the
antichrist is going to manifest in the
last days
so that's one pattern this pattern of
antichrist the other pattern
that we see uh coming up here at the end
of the apocalypse of pseudomethodist is
the idea
of the last king of the romans that's
how he's referred to
in this uh the in the in the uh
um the the latin version of the text
he's called
the the rex romanov you know so the king
of the romans so in other words the last
roman emperor
and there's this idea that the last
roman emperor
um survives like sort of hidden
that the lion of the emperors uh sort of
survives hidden within
the nation of ethiopia and that in the
last
days the last roman emperor manifest
himself
and he he rules over sort of like one
last moment of christian revival
of christian conquests over their
enemies
uh of roman conquest over their enemies
because there's the same thing by this
time
uh before the antichrist comes and that
when the antichrist comes this is what
it says it says the
king the in other words the last roman
emperor will take the crown from his
head
so take the crown off of his head and he
will place it on the cross
and then he will spread out his hands to
the heaven and deliver the kingdom
of the christians to god
and then the cross will be taken up into
heaven along with the king's
crown so this is a prophecy and this is
a long time
this is written several centuries before
the fall of the roman emperor
the empire right that it prophesized
that there's a day coming
when the king's crown so the roman
empire will still sort of exist but only
christ will be
will only have christ as an emperor
because the earthly emperor empire will
have been
brought to an end um
yeah and it's almost like it's the end
but it's the resolution yeah
within that end right right it's it's
becoming
fully what it was supposed to be in its
end at the same time and an interesting
manifestation of this is when
you know in the orthodox church we put
our bishops
in the partially in the garb
of the byzantine emperors yeah right the
the the sacos the
yeah you know the the main investment of
the bishop
is that it's not originally an episcopal
investment it's a it's an imperial
vestment
you know even even charlemagne when he
was coronated
he he sent off to byzantium to get one
because he wanted to associate himself
so he was he was
when charlemagne was crowned he was
coronated in the garb of a byzantine
emperor
yeah very deliberate yeah well i know
that he really wanted to see himself
as the continuation of the byzantine
empire yeah you know
in his succession he's this he's like
the the he's the
he succeeds irene's dead husband
basically right
so when we when we put our our bishops
in this garb
one of the things that we're sort of
saying by that is that the
the kingdom continues but now it's
totally vested in christ right and of
course the bishop
is just like the icon the living icon
you know of christ within
the community of of christians so it
says that
it says that when this happens that the
the cross will be taken up into heaven
along with the king's crown
because the cross in which our lord
jesus christ was hanged for the sake of
the common salvation of all across
itself
will commence to appear before him at
his coming
as a refutation of of the treachery of
unbelievers
and the prophecy of david will be
fulfilled which says
in the last days ethiopia shall stretch
out her hands unto god
because from the sea of the sons of
jesus the daughter
of full the king of ethiopia
these last will stretch out their hands
to god so again there's this idea that
the last roman emperor
somehow survive
or endured in ethiopia manifested in the
last days
and then the kingdom it and then hands
the kingdom over to christ
yeah and it makes sense in terms of the
role of ethiopia we'll talk about it
in another the cosmic role of ethiopia
seems to be in this this universal story
for sure
and so and so you know and then from
that point the story goes kind of
the place that you would expect it to go
which is the antichrist rules over
mankind
in the absence of the of the true roman
emperor things get really bad
the the faithful are persecuted and then
christ returns
and the rights just shine forever as
stars in in in the world
um uh which is which is how which is how
it ends
um so it's a it's a really
beautiful um you could sort of say
extension
of revelation like there's nothing in
the uh which by the way one of the
things that you you'd get a kick out of
is that early on in the apocalypse
we get the the origin of dog-headed men
uh like which
which son of know where they're
descended from so just just uh
tease that out there for people who want
to go looking for it yeah exactly um
but uh there there's we can guess
yeah but the i i really love the
apocalypse of pseudomethodius because it
it really functions as an extension of
revelation like there's nothing in it
that doesn't that's not that's
incompatible like that
the two sort of map onto each other
really really well
and what the apocalypse is doing is it's
trying to a pseudo-methodist is doing is
it's trying to clarify
what's the role of rome it's trying to
clarify
when the roman empire falls and this is
you know hundreds of years before it
falls
you know but when the roman empire falls
is christianity
invalidated does it cease to exist and
the answer is no
um that that uh that basically this
pattern that we see
first see in in the apocalypse of saint
john and that we see foreshadowed in
alexander
in constantine in nero like all these
patterns
that they continue to work themselves
out
in a way that is consistent with
the the ultimate victory of jesus christ
right the the coming the sign of the
coming of the son of man
uh as the as as the text says yeah
and there's also a sense in which rome
persists
uh you know even today people think
that's a funny idea
but you know the ideal of rome is still
continued on you know whether it is in
the two-headed eagle that
that ended up in the austro-hungarian
empire or the same two-headed eagle that
ended up in the russian
uh the russian empire the the they've
saw themselves as a continuation of rome
whether historians like that or not or
whether they think it's legitimate or
not
it it means that the rome had not yet
passed and in a way
rome hasn't yet passed it we're on the i
would say we're
very close to the end of rome in a in a
in a bigger scale because it's like
the idea of rome is kind of has a this
weird
last glimmer in a in the unified europe
but it's a kind of strange perverted
uh you know fragmented version of it but
it the idea of rome is still is still
there and it's still it's not completely
dead
so can i throw one last idea at you go
for it and then we'll we'll then we'll
have another conversation yeah so
sarah nicholas ii the last
russian caesar right
there's a there's a like it's it's to
the point where it's you know maybe sort
of a meme
of like these these young guys who
convert to orthodoxy
and then just develop the biggest
possible man crush on tsar nicholas the
second like i don't know if you've
noticed this oh yeah
well you see it in your facial hair yeah
we don't even have to ask them
because they start to sport the hair the
same facial hair star nicholas
yeah so so that what's really
interesting to me here
is that i think that this is really this
is that same pattern manifesting itself
that the the seed is cut off
right and then it springs up again in
what's the most unlikely place
in the world for a for the veneration of
a russian emperor
to to spring up i would say west
virginia you know like
you know i would say texas like like you
know
you there's you know in america we have
we have multiple layers of
you know we don't like we don't like
kings you know but also like we don't
like russians
and so you know for for the the
veneration of like the last
russian emperor to spring up in such a
surprisingly strong way you know the
devotion
you know to the to the royal family uh
it's also because everybody knows that
there's a relationship between britain
and russia right in terms of that final
emperor
like that the connection is so strong
that one of them became a saint
it's like it's it's so so so it's that's
one of our family saints that's my
daughter is named after saint elizabeth
and so it's not a it's not a it's not as
far
again just like the idea of troy and
arthur and constantine and arthur you
know
in these surprising joining together the
the the connection between the extreme
east and the extreme west or the
you know these two extremes of the world
in the
in the character of tsar nicholas is
something which i think is playing
in narrative function as well and and
that's i mean so in our last episode you
famously said that america is the [ __ ]
of babylon
um so but we're also and i stand by that
i know i know
it's fine
one of the things that's i i'm going to
try to have a
conversation i think with paul vander
clay about why why did the medieval
model
why did we lose it like what happened
why did that transition happen and one
of the things that people don't always
understand
is that one of the things that brings
about the end of the medieval model is
the discovery of the new world
that there is such an influx of
resources gold
and other things from the new world like
we can't even understand
how how much it just destroyed the
traditional trade networks and economy
economic things that were kind of
holding western europe together
but but basically you know but america
is the
is the sort of it is the end it's the
it's the in one sense like it's the
ultimate margin
yeah right especially especially
california california yeah that's
exactly what i was getting to california
seattle right that these are they're
they're
it's as far west as you can go like it's
the end
yeah you can't go you can't go west any
farther after that it's east
yeah exactly and but there's something
also interesting like if you look at
california
it's an interesting it's interesting how
you can see some of the seeds
how can i say this like it's california
also has a microcosmic form like
structure and it has it has aspects of
it which is actually
the most like traditional right uh
you know most spiritually alive place
and also the worst degeneracy that you
can ever
where was the same spot where was father
sarah from that's right
he's in california he's like as
you know like as sort of like hardcore
traditionalist as you could sort of
possibly imagine
right uh and and uh yeah cause
because it's but it's it's the same
thing it's you get to the edge you get
to the end of the world
and all that's left is the remainder
you know so uh so king arthur will land
you know on the west coast yeah
somewhere in california
i wouldn't i wouldn't be like totally
surprised if that happened honestly i
i'm but anyway i i think that sarah
nicholas is
i think that he is manifesting um
he's manifesting this pattern and that's
why like i don't really mind like i'm
i'm happy to see you know a lot of a lot
of these
these guys like they know intuitively
like in their hearts they need a king
you know and uh you know of course then
ultimately that's christ but then to
also
to also like have this deep love for
kind of like the last emperor
who is who is manifesting again you know
as a saint
he's manifesting again in in the the
most unlikely of places yeah i think is
i think that's that's another way that
we see this pattern kind of playing out
in the orthodox church right now and i
and i do think it's actually
ultimately a beautiful thing yeah i
think so too
all right well look we i think this
problem might have been the longest
conversation that i've had in the
in i probably on my channel how long was
it i don't know like
an hour and a half maybe which is
totally cool i didn't even
i didn't even notice that it was it was
great and so next
next next conversation we will
definitely go into all the mysteries of
ethiopia and i'm looking forward to that
definitely so thanks everybody
for your time and your energy and
richard go ahead and plug again
all the things you're involved in
because yeah stuff the big thing
um is of course i'm on the admin school
podcast if you want to hear me talk
tolkien um i'm actually pretty excited
about this next
episode that'll be coming out on the
10th of june
because i had dr lisa kudris back on
to talk about marian figures in
tolkien's legendarium and this is the
the like i'm always nervous about
talking about the mother of god because
i feel like she's the sort of like you
just can't talk about her you have to
you have to venerate an icon i don't
know what else to say um and yet i keep
finding myself places where i'm where
where i am talking about her so this is
like the most marion thing that i've
ever done
on the internet um and i'm pretty
excited about this episode uh we're
we are also still working on getting a
website up for
a book that i want to publish um and
hopefully you'll be contributing to it
and some other people will be
contributing to
contributing to it's called finding the
golden key essays on a
toward our recovery of the sacramental
imagination and it's kind of
i'm hoping it's going to be sort of a
nexus for this
project of re-enchantment that we've all
kind of been involved in
so look for that i'm hoping the website
will go up in the next week or two
and you'll be able to people will be
able to actually submit abstracts
for essays to be included in the volume
so
all right everybody so stay tuned and uh
and we'll definitely be back with some
some other surprising and wondrous
wonderful wondrous story so thanks
everybody